[Musik]
hallo herr boss war die einladung
ja ich freue mich auch schön dass sie
hier sind sie haben es ja vielleicht
schon gesehen wir sind ein youtube
format aber damit sie sich so ein
bisschen wohlfühlen dachte ich ich mache
die klassische talkshow begrüßung mit
ihnen quasi unsere kamera dann und ich
lege dann einfach mal los und drehen
nicht so klassisch 1 dreht sich herzlich
willkommen bei fabians wm-studio
meingast heute wolfgang bosbach danke
für die einladung ist youtube nach so
lasse sich so ein bisschen frecher
entlassen wird das ist somit sind also
ich mach's noch einmal herzlich
willkommen bei fabians wm-studio
meingast heute wolfgang bosbach mein
gastgeber fabian ja wo sind mein vierter
gast und bis jetzt hat sich niemand
getraut mit mir alkohol zu trinken und
das während der wm wird es wenigstens
ein kleines bier als rheinländer vor mir
aus auch in großen ich muss ja heuer
fahren zum wurst zum wohle so jetzt
lassen wir uns noch tätowieren oder mehr
wir hier in der danke fürs gespräch ich
gucke aber gerne dabei zu wie wir es
jetzt bald rum irgendwie sie sind ja
auch schon in rente das politik angeht
von daher habe ich mir überlegt dass wir
heute mal so ein bisschen entspannten
look machen so einfach so schön
jogginganzug sind sie dabei naja gut zu
bekommen
oha gute bauch einziehen dann geht es
nach brega oder aber man fühlt sich
nicht entspannt jetzt oder direkt von
der kamera dabei und wer man aber
einfach mal die seele baumeln lassen und
man muss ja nicht immer seinen job
machen den seehofer machen kann sie
warum er ist ja auch die seele baumeln
ist mir jetzt nicht so sehr auf gefahren
finden sie ja macht seine arbeit als
innenminister er macht seine arbeit als
innenminister
haben sie denn eigentlich noch freunde
in der cdu und warum nicht nur von der
cdu warum nicht erst erfahren wir mal
vorne an
gemessen an der anzahl der einladung von
stadt und kreisverbänden müssen ist
unglaublich viele sein dass sich die
zahl der fans in der parteizentrale in
grenzen hält glaube ich sofort sie
wissen also wie es ist von der eigenen
truppe im stich gelassen zu werden was
hat er nie so gefühlt was soll ich jetzt
tun hab ja so habe ich mich nie so
gefühlt es wäre gut wenn er sich äußern
würde wenn er sich nicht äußert ist das
auch und steht mit irgendwann muss es
auch mal gut sein
wäre deutschland ein besseres land wenn
böse zurücktritt und dafür innenminister
wird özil zurücktritt von aus der
nationalmannschaft ja das haben wir den
richtigen deutschland genau so besser
als wenn horst seehofer im mittelfeld
spielen
naja also horst seehofer wäre schon mal
weg sehe ich als vorteil
warum kein theater mehr die csu spielt
das spiel ja seit 2005 10
da kann man noch weiter zurückgehen bis
mindestens 1976 aber man stellt fest am
ende gibt es keine sieger es gibt nur
verlierer
meinen sie das wird sich ändern wenn
endlich die bayerischen landtag soll
vorbei ist das liegt wahrscheinlich vom
ergebnis der bayerische landtagswahl ab
jedenfalls will ich hoffe dass dann das
theater nicht wieder mit neuer besetzung
oder mit neuen themen beginnt da sind
sie denn in erster linie politiker
gewesen oder doch talkshow gast gemessen
an der zeit würde ich sagen 99 prozent
politiker und darin das kommt jetzt
anderes brauchen ist ja sagt er wird
viel unsinn geredet überraschend ich
habe mir nie mit gewalt zutritt
verschafft ich bin immer eingeladen
worden und konnte dabei nur wie dieses
jahr möbeln auch einen bruchteil der
einladungen annehmen
sie merken wolfgang muss man bescheiden
ich habe tatsächlich noch ein spiel
vorbereitet was spielen wir hier spielen
jährigen was warum playstation ja können
sie das nicht sehr gut
doch sowieso und die regelschule ist der
dreh vorbereitet ist noch vor bereits
jetzt drücken sie es warum dafür zweiter
gehen also ja das kann man heute nicht
mehr aus wir sind ein argument
so wollen wir noch ihre aufstellung
bearbeiten ich kenne die brüder
allerdings also nicht wer radio arbeit
ich kenne die brüder nicht ist aber auch
so cdu ein förderung spricht nein ich
will ich weiß nicht was ich dir nicht
ich erkläre in meinem betrieb sich ja
wohl so schuster den ball bekommt jetzt
andere kommt gut und sixx ist sie müssen
zu hören
ich jedenfalls nicht also wir sind so
ich kann gucken tören gleichzeitig
sensationell egal ist passt ja passen ja
wohin wenn ja wenn wir den ball haben ja
wohin der jetzt nicht ich habe ja noch
immer werden wir nicht angestoßen wie
sollen sie dann ihren jeweilig anstoß
hat warum sehen sie doch da ich hab die
seitenwahl geworden wärst du gar nicht
mitgewählt ja das macht der computer
also so und ja bei xxx praxis beim
werfen des paars das ist schuss zack da
war mesut die wichtige frage ist ja hat
er die hunde eben mitgesungen
ich freue mich wenn die jungs mit singen
aber mehreren spieler der nicht singt
und vorschrift irgendwie lieber
auseinander singt und nicht dem was
mache ich jetzt wie kann ich den hobby
spieler bewegen meine ja mit dem ihr das
riecht noch mal klar gesagt mitnehmen
mit dem ihr mit dem messer mit dem
rechten der ist den kann man auch aber
das geht jetzt so ist jetzt zu hoch was
macht er denn jetzt ich habe ihnen den
ball abgenommen und durch nicht allein
vom tor wäre der macht ihn nicht
ja
wir haben jetzt ja irgendwann sie haben
ja auch zu mir gepasst können sie nur
sie müssen ja gleichzeitig lenken und
passen sonst macht sie das sagen sie mir
jetzt sonder führungsstab ich habe ihnen
gesagt dass man damit lenkt also hat an
diesem komisches 3com kopf das heißt
dass sie das sind danach das habe ich
ihnen noch eben erklärt das blaue
herrchen da oben sind sie so wir haben
den ball schießen sieg kreis ist schoss
kreisausschuss jetzt sechsmal mit der
entwicklung ist der schlanke mann
christian ja sie war ja bis jetzt noch
nicht wirklich in der gelegenheit eine
flanke zu schon was ist kostbar sagt wir
haben einfach geflankt während ich ihm
schon erklären
ja klar wieso ist ja unglaublich so muss
man drauf drücken
raten sie mal x-serie arbeit musste man
hüten denn ich habe auch kein witz
doch das ist ja ich kann da kommt ja ich
weiß nicht ob sie das überfordert also
sie können das hütchen sogar wächst ich
weiß nicht ob natürlich immer vor der
frage wo soll ich über solche pläne sind
ja nicht alle elf spielern hütchen geben
was mach ja so hat mich hier noch
niemand zum lachen geschickt was heißt
zum lachen als bitterer ernst
ich verstehe dass jetzt also überwiegend
und jetzt schießen sie schießen nicht
schießen sie nein nein nein ich kann sie
haben sich sehr gut geschlagen
gott sei dank konnte ich ihnen was beine
was ich deshalb völlig neues leben das
ich jetzt wirklich auftut
ich habe bis jetzt immer für die
politiker gerät aber sie haben ja gar
keinen hunger ich denke ihre aufgabe ist
es politiker zu grillen hahaha findet
ihr das genauso lustig wie oft das war
ganz cool schreibt es in die kommentare
also hier sind die würstchen so das
sieht doch gut aus ist hier schon mal
erfolgreich und lehrern viel strom
produziert worden
jawohl wir mal und teller packen
sieht doch gut aus haben wir jetzt auf
den teller packen sieht man gut auf
hören sie mir
doch so meine frau sagt auch immer ich
würde nicht zuhört ich krieg alles mit
ich reagieren muss man bin sehr
zufrieden
jetzt können wir noch was cooles sagen
wir sind ja immer noch auf youtube waren
uns doch cool und sehr cool runnings
[Musik]